la tragédie s'amplifie dans l'est du
zaïre environ un million de réfugiés
sont en effet livrés à leur sort
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
élections en roumanie avec toujours
beaucoup de nostalgie de l'époque
ceausescu émotion ce matin aux sables
d'olonne lors du départ des seize
concurrents du vendée globe à bercy
victoire du suédois enquist et puis dans
ce journal également reportage sur les
progrès tout à fait étonnant en matière
de radiologie grâce au scanner et la
visite du musée les carences du château
de versailles
madame monsieur bonsoir elles et ils
sont partis joyeux mais un peu émue pour
une course très très lointaine
les 16 participants du vendée globe ont
pris le départ à 13 heures aujourd'hui
aux sables d'olonne et plonger pour près
de quatre mois dans la solitude de
l'immensité marine un reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux
christophe duchiron frédérick basile le
bon départ c'était pour bertrand de broc
il était 13h02 l'heure des adieux pour
isabelle autissier
pour yves parlier pour christophe auguin
et tous les autres l'adieu aux siens et
à la terre entière
désormais leur terrain de jeu c'est la
planète mère 100 jours de solitude pour
trois hommes et deux femmes qui vont en
découdre avec le pire le meilleur des
océans tempête froid et vent des
centaines de bateaux accompagnateurs
bateau à ivato chéri le maillot jaune
bertrand de broc salué par type ou son
préparateur son pote qui tous 7h ce
matin le café au goût un peu plus amer
que d'habitude qui tous travaillent
depuis toujours avec bertrand
cette fois encore il a donné son temps
sa compétence son énergie il a donné son
corps à la science de v reprend son pote
qui met les voiles
ça fait bizarre de voir les bateaux ce
voile partir tout seul
non un copain qui part et qui reviendra
partie revenu un copain qui part à matin
l'émotion et le dernier baiser des
soeurs sourire isabelle autissier
catherine chabaud 13 hommes et 2 femmes
sur la mer pour faire le tour du monde
pas facile pour ceux qui partent pas
facile pour ceux qui restent
les derniers instants on n'oublie pas le
discours est très très court c'est dos
au revoir et puis bonne chance et bon
vent mais pas non plus sortir les
mouchoirs mais bon quinze bateaux deux
parties ça fait du vide sur les pontons
15 barrette par coup ça fait du vide
dans les coeurs
tennis pas de doublé parisien pourrait
regagner kafelnikov le russe vainqueur
de roland garros cette année en effet
été battu en finale de l'open de bercy
par le suédois thomas scène christ qui
n'a pas perdu un seul set durant ce
tournoi
d'une manière générale la bonne forme
des joueurs suédois est plutôt de
mauvais augure pour les français à un
peu moins d'un mois de la finale de la
coupe davis
françois brabant ça n'est pas dans ses
habitudes mais pour une fois thomas
scène christ à la banane un bon fruit et
un petit sourire le suédois peu desserré
les dents car sur le coup rehnquist
c'est plutôt aux mâchoires crispées et
tennis en force 1 mètre 91 et 85 kg de
puissance brute avec parfois quelques
grammes de finesse en face de lui est
venue kafelnikov non plus n'a pas le
sourire mais là ça n'a rien à voir avec
de la concentration c'est plutôt de la
consternation pendant deux sets en effet
perdu 6 2 6 4 le russe est totalement
absente cette finale
le troisième set est plus équilibrée
kafelnikov est enfin entré dans la
partie mais enquist ne se laisse pas
surprendre
le suédois revient de 0,3 à 3 partout et
à cinq partout il donne un dernier coup
d'accélérateur
score final 6-2 6-4 7-5
à moins d'un mois de la finale de la
coupe davis les français sont prévenus
si ça continue de rigoler pour in christ
ça ne sera pas une partie de plaisir
tragédie humaine dans l'est du zaïre
coupé du monde environ un million de
réfugiés rwandais et burundais mais
aussi de civils zaïrois chassés par les
combats r en effet sur les routes livré
à la faim et aux épidémies
après l'évacuation des derniers
personnels humanitaires de la ville de
goma hier matin reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux martine laroche-joubert michel
levasseur nicolas la tension quartier
général du hcr le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés à goma avant l'évacuation de
cent trente personnes
une opération à hauts risques les
conditions de travail sont devenues trop
dangereuses au dehors les habitants de
goma fui les bombardements à
l'artillerie lourde
au milieu des tirs d'armes automatiques
les rues sont désertées
mais quelques pillards semble déjà se
servir au passage
nous apercevons les assaillants venus du
rwanda
ils ne portent pas l'uniforme de l'armée
régulière rwandaise
mais emploie une tactique de guérilla
bien éprouvée l'armée zaïroise elle
semble s'être évanoui
10 heures l'évacuation au nom de code
bien trouvé pique nique au bord du lac
le lac est à côté de la frontière aéro
rwandaise quelques minutes de route dans
le champ de bataille
avant de rejoindre le poste frontière de
guissény
nous sommes au rwanda et les
humanitaires s'inquiètent pour tous les
réfugiés qu'ils laissent derrière eux
restait à voir d'énormes problèmes en ce
qui concerne la nourriture parce que
déjà on avait une ration réduite pour
cette semaine qu'on n'a même pas pu
distribuer parce que elle était divisée
en deux on avait dissous mais le reste
hier et aujourd'hui on n'a pas pu le
faire et de ce côté je vois les choses
ce métier mais il très rapidement le
camp de mugunga côté de goma où nous
étions il ya trois jours
aujourd'hui plus personne ne leur
portent assistance pas de nourriture pas
de médicaments ce drapeau de la croix
rouge ne flotte plus pour près d'un
million de réfugiés
et pendant ce temps les diplomates se
hâte lentement les dirigeants de huit
parties de huit pays africains vont se
retrouver mardi à nairobi pour tenter de
dénouer la crise et les responsables de
l'union européenne et des organisations
humanitaires se réuniront jeudi à
bruxelles
sur le terrain les rebelles tutsis
continuent leur progression apparemment
dans l'est du zaïre provoquant une
sérieuse crise au sein de l'armée
régulière
iroise patrice lacoste l'armée zaïroise
effondré mise en déroute en deux
semaines sur sa frontière avec le rwanda
tente de sauver la face au chef
d'état-major accusent le gouvernement
le gouvernement n'a pas de bouger
réellement nous insistons pour que le
gouvernement fasse on travaille on
puisse donner les moyens aux armées et
les forces armées montreront de quoi
elles sont capables
sur le terrain les militaires aéro à
contre attaque ray des duels
d'artillerie ont été entendus la nuit
dernière à quelques kilomètres de cette
frontière autour de l'aéroport de bukavu
les derniers témoins des religieux qui à
leur tour la zone le visage grave elle
s'abandonne à leur sort des centaines de
milliers de réfugiés
seul espoir la déclaration du vainqueur
le chef des rebelles tutsis qui appelle
les organisations humanitaires à revenir
et qui parle d'ouvrir les aéroports d'où
vira et de bukavu au sud à deal it et
politiques ou réalité c'est une surprise
le but de l'anac des rebelles tutsis et
tentent aussi de se débarrasser du
million et demi de réfugiés hutus qu'il
considère comme une menace
en tout cas les organisations
humanitaires confiant tenté de négocier
avec les rebelles tutsis et pré
positionne des vivres aux frontières
au-delà plus d'image seul le témoignage
en voici du consul honoraire français
restait à goma joint au téléphone
près d'un million de personnes se
massent retz près du lac kivu dans une
petite baie qui rien n'est fait dans les
48 heures ce ne sera plus la peine à
genève les responsables du haut
commissariat aux réfugiés réclame avec
insistance l'ouverture de couloirs
humanitaires dans cette région pour
pouvoir faire transiter un minimum de
vivre et de secours
un avion de l'unicef devrait partir ce
soir pour l'ouganda avec trente tonnes
de matériel médical à bord une cargaison
somme toute dérisoire face à l'ampleur
des besoins
nous retrouvons en direct de kigali la
capitale du rwanda notre envoyé spécial
de martine laroche-joubert martin
bonsoir on le dit on le redit on ne
redira jamais assez
des centaines de milliers de réfugiés
sont totalement abandonnés à leur sort
oui la situation dans l'est du zaïre est
vraiment catastrophique
il ya maintenant autour de goma près
d'un million de réfugiés des rondes et
des burundais et puis aussi des zaïrois
qui fut les combats et il n'y a plus
personne pour leur donner de la
nourriture ou des médicaments est là
pour éviter une catastrophe bien il
faudrait soit qu'il y ait des corridors
humanitaires soient que les
organisations internationales reviennent
mais c'est difficile pour des raisons de
sécurité absence également de tout
journaliste donc éventuellement de
témoins gênants
non il n'y a absolument plus aucun
journaliste dans la région et toujours
pour des raisons de sécurité
alors y at il cependant martin quelques
signes encourageants pour dans ce
désastre général il ya peut-être
quelques signes encourageants d'abord
paul kagame l'homme fort du rwanda a
annoncé qu'ils participeraient peut-être
à la conférence régionale de nairobi sur
la situation dans l'est du zaïre
et puis le chef des rebelles tutsis qui
a conquis le sud kivu a annoncé aussi
qu'il demandait aux organisations
humanitaires de revenir merci beaucoup
martin lange vert pour ces précisions
dimanche électoral dans trois pays de
l'est en bulgarie tout d'abord deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle selon
deux instituts de sondage péta stoyanov
le candidat de l'opposition de droite
devanceraient assez largement son rival
yvan marc azoff le représentant de l'ex
parti communiste
actuellement au pouvoir élections
également en serbie et monténégro les
premières depuis la fin de la guerre et
en roumanie un peu plus de 17 millions
d'électeurs votent est aujourd'hui pour
le renouvellement du parlement et le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle la bataille s'annonce
incertaine pour l'actuel président
roumain lyonniais lescout et son parti
au pouvoir depuis la chute de ceausescu
en 89
une chute qui suscite toujours
apparemment une certaine nostalgie au
sein au moins d'une partie de la
population roumaine reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux
stéphane magnier marcel martin le grand
cimetière de bucarest n'est pas
seulement un endroit où l'on se promène
le dimanche en profitant du soleil
d'automne on vient aussi pour laitiers
au tce secoue voir la tombe d'elena que
voici
l'épousé du dictateur qui lui repose
quelques dizaines de mètres plus loin
sous cette croix il avait été enterré à
la sauvette il y a six ans après leur
exécution sans pierres tombales des
couronnes de simples tertre anonyme dans
la rumeur avait fini par percer le
secret est que les gens ordinaires
désormais viennent honorer ils ont érigé
cette croix depuis quelques années c'est
le parti des travailleurs qui l'a fait
c'est pour ça que les autorités n'osent
pas la démolir on aurait bien aimé faire
un monument plus important et on n'a pas
le droit
si la terre est brûlée par les cendres
des bougies c'est que les sépultures des
ceausescu sont devenus des symboles des
lieux où l'on exprime son amertume
la difficulté à s'adapter à un monde
dont les règles ont changé et
l'injustice dont on croit être victimes
on a travaillé toute notre vie et si on
a même plus de quoi vivre
il ya maintenant des milliardaires dans
ce pays ce sont même les anciens
dirigeants qui sont devenus riches nous
la classe ouvrière tuer ou c'est ce qui
nous manque on se rend compte
aujourd'hui qu'on avait les maisons et
du travail à l'époque aujourd'hui des
jeunes n'ont ni travail ni argent pour
aller à l'université
avant mon congélateur était plein et
maintenant je peux à peine me payer un
kilo de viande par mois le loyer a
atteint des sommes astronomiques sans
parler d'électricité et du run et ce
forum improvisés se prolongera jusqu'à
la fermeture
près des deux tombes ou d'une troisième
la plus récente et la plus fleurie celle
du fils nick ou mort il ya tout juste un
mois
ces laissés-pour-compte de l'économie de
marché ils ont ensuite voté pour des
politiciens qui les laisse sceptique
en oubliant qu autrefois la misère il
n'avait même pas le droit d'en parler
élection également mardi aux etats-unis
guère de suspense en ce qui concerne
l'élection présidentielle le démocrate
bill clinton devrait normalement
continuer de conduire les destinées de
son pays jusqu'à l'aube du troisième
millénaire nous retrouvons en direct de
washington l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux
daniel bilalian daniel bonsoir comme
dans toute bonne campagne électorale qui
se prolonge les arguments vole
maintenant au ras des pâquerettes et
certains électeurs ne trouve pas ça
drôle comme dirait philippe harrouard
effectivement un ça n'est pas très drôle
pour bob doll car il a encore pas mal de
retard dans les sondages mais il fait
tout pour rattraper ce retard en ce
moment il faut dire que les deux
candidats à la présidence et bien monter
et descendre d'avion en permanence pour
tenter de convaincre les derniers
hésitants pour convaincre et rassembler
également leur propre camp et les
échanges wall effectivement assez bas
bref dans le s'interrogent sur la nature
des fonds du candidat bill clinton
il dit que l'argent vient pour une bonne
partie d'indonésie ou encore de taiwan
et bill clinton lui répond d'un ton tout
aussi sec en lui disant que lui et bien
son argent à lui bob dole ils pullulent
pétrole voyez l'argent des partis
politiques comme en france et bien c'est
un des thèmes de la campagne
présidentielle ici aux etats unis
autre thème de campagne très important
ces dernières 24 heures
l'immigration comme en france
l'immigration ici elle vient
principalement d'amérique centrale et du
mexique les deux candidats sont d'accord
pour renforcer les mesures à la
frontière ça qu'ils sont d'accord tous
les deux mais ben abdul veut aller plus
loin
il veut mettre l'armée à la frontière
mexicaine et il veut interdire aux
enfants de clandestins qui sont parvenus
à s'infiltrer aux états unis leur
interdire d'aller dans les écoles
publiques
bill clinton lui n'est pas d'accord en
attendant c'est un véritable mur qui est
en train de s'installer de se construire
à la frontière mexicaine comme l'ont
constaté nos envoyés spéciaux dirigée
par philippe gassot reportage
une arrestation de plus une goutte les
immigrants illégaux n'ont jamais été
aussi nombreux elle a essayé de donner
une autre vie à son fils trois jours de
bus passait le mur elle recommencera
chaque jour des dizaines de mexicains se
taillent
chaque jour des centaines passe à
nogales les 160 gardes frontières font
ce qu'ils peuvent
impossible avec les effectifs et les
moyens mis en oeuvre d'endiguer le flot
ceux qui sont rattrapés c'est à dire la
grande majorité seront reconduits à la
frontière
l'amérique ne gardera que les criminels
fichés les candidats au passage sont
souvent arrêtés des dizaines de fois
parfois deux fois par jour ceux-ci
ramené à la frontière à midi nous les
retrouverons en ville deux heures plus
tard les gardes n'ont pas d'états d'âme
je suis désolé pour les gens qui
traversent pour essayer de trouver une
meilleure vie et je sais ce qu'ils
ressentent je suis moi-même un immigré
mais j'ai un travail à faire et je dois
le faire le mieux que je peux
notre présence la caméra qui les fait
hésiter côté mexique à les illégaux sont
exploités volet ils payent leurs
passagers faux papiers entre 500 et 1000
$ pour eux des fortunes la nuit des
caméras balaient le mur et guide les
patrouilles
ceux qui ont pu passer tente de monter
vers le nord vers phoenix s'accrocher au
train très surveillée ou alors par la
route le point de contrôle obliger et
souvent contournées à pied la drogue
passe par ici dans les voitures est ce
que vous êtes gêné par tous ces
contrôles
je sais pas je crois que c'est bien
s'ils cherchent des terroristes mais en
fait il n'ya que la drogue prigest
intéresse les illégaux passe quand même
en dépit des contrôles toujours plus
nombreux même si les peines encourues
sont lourdes prison et amende
il n'est pas possible de quitter la
région de nogales sans passer par ce
point de contrôle toute drogue trouvée
dans un véhicule entraînera
automatiquement saisi et sa vente aux
enchères dans les prochains jours la
rédaction de france 2 va bien évidemment
multiplié les éditions spéciales sur ces
élections aux états unis notamment lors
de la soirée du 5 novembre avec jean
nous de mieux à washington et philippe
lefait à paris page spéciale également
le 6 novembre dans télématin un décalage
horaire oblige à 13 heures et à 20
heures en russie boris eltsine devrait
être opéré du coeur en début de semaine
l'opération devrait durer entre six et
huit heures
la russie qui se portent apparemment
mieux que son président lentement ce
pays se normalise sinon se modernise
exemple avec ce reportage tout à fait
étonnant de notre correspondant
permanent de mines guerdat sur deux
jeunes filles chargées des contrôles de
santé publique qu en quelque sorte les
starsky et hutch de la boulangerie
industrielle à reportage qui ne mange
pas de pain elle arrive au pas de charge
et frappe sans prévenir
natacha et natacha sont les inspectrices
de choc de la police du pain les
services sanitaires de la ville de
moscou qui depuis peu au nom de la
défense du consommateur une idée
en russie sèment la terreur dans les
boulangeries industrielles de la
capitale c'est natacha numéro un qui
passe à l'offensive
non mais sans blague vous appelez ça lui
peut regarder
il est même pas cuit
natacha numéro 2 n'en perd pas une
miette et attendez un peu les filles est
encore chaud se passe et tout mais non
il n'est plus chez nadiejda ivanovna la
patronne n'aime guère la tournure que
prend cette visite surprise mais les
deux natacha sont du genre tenace elle
ne s'arrêteront pas en si bon chemin
aujourd'hui vous vous posez à les voir
un peu par ici
regardez-moi ça devrait être tout propre
et tout blanc nettoyer il ya un jour à
peine et la regarder c'est tout moi si
je vous dis qu'on nettoie tous les jours
et ça continue une à une
elle inspecte toutes les machines
nadiejda yves van horne a ou est-ce que
vous vous cachez encore venir ici et ça
vous l'avez nettoyer fort pour la
dernière fois tu erres hier et c'est
dans cet état oui je vous jure
une demi heure à peine après l'arrivée
des deux inspectrices il faut se rendre
à l'évidence pour tout remettre en état
les employés ont du pain sur la planche
et ce n'est pas un rapide coup de balai
dernière minute qui changera grand chose
à la fin on va fermer ses cuisines
quelques tomes le temps qu'il répare les
machines et qu'il nettoie tout devoir
mettre la clé sous la porte même rien
que quelques jours c'est perdre beaucoup
d'argent alors certaines de ses usines
ont parfois recours à des méthodes
plutôt musclées
bien sûr on reçoit parfois des menaces
du genre si vous fermez attention à vos
enfants
ça arrive
nadiejda ivanovna n'ira pas jusque là
elles promettent à contrecoeur de faire
un grand ménage et les voilà repartis
dos 2 incorruptibles natacha il
s'attacha à l'assaut d'une autre
boulangerie industrie un mot de
politique française pour relever ce
pronostic de jacques toubon devant le
grand jury rtl le monde ce soir ce qui
miserait sur le départ d'alain juppé de
matignon vont perdre
on a l'impression que certains jouent à
très court terme je crois qu'ils se
trompent pas déclaré le garde des sceaux
sans préciser toutefois qui il visait à
marseille les autorités policières sont
sur les dents la ville accueille en
effet lundi mardi 22 ministres au total
pour un sommet franco espagnol qui sera
donc placée sous très haute sécurité par
crainte bien sûr d'attentats de la part
de militants basques ou corses
reportage alban nicosie lucien t on dans
les allées du palais du pharo dans les
jardins autour des bâtiments
ils sont partout ils ce sont les
fonctionnaires de police près d'un
millier mobilisés pour la surveillance
de ce sommet reste se demande des forces
de sécurité qui sont visibles mais
également des bords sont beaucoup moins
visible sécurité maximum aussi autour
des chambres à coucher ici celle d'alain
juppé
l'hôtel où sont accueillis les
délégations a presque été entièrement
vidé ensuite le président jacques chirac
l'établissement a accueilli le dalaï
lama le juge falcone par exemple alors
ici on se dit confiant presque rodez ce
sera luxe calme et volupté avec vue
imprenable sur le port de marseille
autre site sensible l'hôtel de ville
c'est d'ici que se tiendra la première
réunion au sommet entre les chefs d'état
le quartier sera leur interdit à toute
circulation de véhicules bien sûr mais
aussi de bateau dans le vieux port et
les cafés des alentours seront fermées
dès 14 heures vous pouvez fermer
vous marquez pour confirmer leur père ne
s'est pas arrêté là pour me dire à tes
dents tout en formulant j'ai fermé la
volonté générale et de ne pas trop
bouleverser le quotidien des marseillais
toutefois les menaces d'actions
terroristes sont ici près ce très au
sérieux avec le recours notamment à la
marine nationale
il n'y aura pas de bain de foule pour
les présidents marseille est une ville
que sa géographie tourmentée rend
difficile à surveiller à béziers de
coups de feu de gros calibre ont été
tirées hier après midi contre le
domicile et la voiture d'un conseiller
municipal de cette ville lundi dernier
la maison du maire raymond couderc avait
été la cible d'un attentat à la bombe
qui aurait pu s'avérer très meurtrier
reportage karine castelli françoise maso
une grille percer une voiture endommagée
des éclats de fer disséminés dans la
porte d'entrée
c'est une attaque aux gros calibres qui
a eu lieu chez ce tranquille conseiller
municipal de béziers
georges fajer délégué aux espaces verts
ne comprend pas de qui il est la cible
je suis un élu mais une écologiste aussi
mais de là à trouver des personnes qui
soient capables de tirer un coup de feu
par vengeance
je ne me connaît pas déjà après
l'attentât du maire de paris c'est que
ça s'arrêtera là et maintenant on aurait
vu deux mois
d autres s'ils disent à qui le tour pour
le moins détective les deux attentats en
moins d'une semaine et des pistes pour
le moins brouillée règlement de comptes
locales ou actes d'intimidation venant
de l'extérieur
la police judiciaire de montpellier
poursuit lé enquête mais béziers 10 dans
l'anxiété
béziers est une ville calme mais c'est
vrai que les ces fous qui ont réalisé
ces attentats contribuer à donner une
image négative de la ville et c'est pour
ça que je souhaite que le plus vite
possible on sache de qui s'agit il
vraiment faire quelque chose ça ne peut
plus durer comme ça c'est certain
le commissariat de béziers a appelé en
renfort une demi compagnie de crs pour
effectuer des rondes en attendant que la
ville retrouve la paix le saviez-vous
pour réparer le cerveau les chirurgiens
passe parfois par la cuisse je
schématise à peine les radiologues
réunis en congrès à partir de demain à
paris ne se contente plus de faire des
images
ils peuvent également soigné grâce aux
progrès spectaculaires de la technique
du scanner comme le montre ce reportage
de jean bnf les akyé et bernard connor
la patiente qui est caché sous le drap
est une jeune femme de 23 ans une des
artères de son cerveau à saigner une
hémorragie due à cette petite boule que
l'on appelle un ami brice une
malformation une sorte de hernie à la
surface de la terre qui peut seront et
provoquer des hémorragies pour réparer
ce dommage elle n'est pas dans un bloc
opératoire mais dans une salle de
radiologie et les radiologues vont
devoir aller déposer ce si cette petite
pire d'à peine 3 mm dans l'année prisme
pour le colmater une opération très
compliquée car il faudra en déposer en
fait plusieurs de ces petites spire et
pour cela on va passer par une artère de
la cuisse est montée jusqu'au cerveau
cela paraît simple mais en fait c'est
très long parce qu'il faut slalomer
prendre des virages parfois revenir en
arrière
jusqu'au moment où on atteindra enfin
l'anévrisme et on pourra y déposer la
précieuse petite fille
une technique que l'on appelle
radiologie interventionnelle et qui
aujourd'hui se développe beaucoup en
médecine ce sont de plus en plus la
place des patients qui auraient pu
bénéficier essayons de la chirurgie et
pour lesquelles on préfère il ya
quelques mois à l'asie utilisé depuis
longtemps pour dilater les artères
coronaires la radiologie
interventionnelle sert aussi aujourd'hui
allait injecter des produits
anticancéreux directement dans les
tumeurs une méthode parfois moins
coûteuse que la chirurgie et par ces
temps d'économie de santé
c'est un argument qui compte
connaissez-vous george soros le
milliardaire américain d'origine
hongroise se présente lui-même comme un
financier philosophe et un spectateur
philanthrope spéculateurs efficace car
lors de son attaque sur la livre
sterling en 92 il aurait engrangé sur ce
seul coup plus de 5 milliards de francs
de bénéfices françoise laborde a
rencontré ce financier de haut vol
actuellement à paris pour la promotion
de son livre le défi de larges
spéculateurs ou philanthrope george
soros refi de l'opposition même s'il a
bâti sa fortune sur le marché boursier
même s'il a créé des fondations pour
promouvoir sa conception de la
démocratie à l'est se sont dit il les
mêmes principes qu'il applique à chaque
fois je suis assez implacable dans les
fondations c'est il y a deux fausses
idées une fausse idée c'est l'idée des
spéculateurs comme une force de mal et
je ne suis pas l'image d'un pull en
trope qui parce que il y a des principes
il faut suivre dans les fondations et
c'est pas la charité
mais ce pécule est heureux doute et qui
fit tomber la livre sterling ébranla le
système monétaire européen en 92 a aussi
créé 24 fondation à l'aise depuis 20 ans
auquel il a déjà consacré la moitié de
ses revenus
plus de 500 milliards de francs après la
chute du communisme c'est pour bâtir une
nouvelle société basée sur delannoy la
démocratie respecte pour les minorités
c'est une conception politique
paradoxalement george soros est un
partisan de la monnaie unique mais son
diagnostic est pessimiste car les états
ne veulent pas s'engager dans une
véritable europe intégrée
il ya tellement de résistance que le
pack devrait venir ne viendra pas à
cause de ça on va être dans un position
de déséquilibre s il ya un danger que le
mot nuit sera cassée après son travail à
travers les fondation george soros veut
maintenant le développer à l'ouest où
ils trouvent que quelque chose ne va pas
non plus car l'homme ne doute de rien
même pas de sa capacité à pouvoir
changer le moz roulant carrosse comme
dirait jean soros à l'occasion de
l'opération invitation musée la gratuité
dans quelques 700 musées de france le
dimanche et cela jusqu'au 17 novembre le
musée national des carrosses du château
de versailles en effet ouvert
exceptionnellement ses portes aux
visiteurs parmi lesquels matuchet et
jean-louis qu'eric
j'en sculpté airbags intérieur klaxons
personnalisés le château de versailles
vous présente ses plus belles berlines
une dizaine de cars fabriqués en série
pour le mariage de napoléon 1er
au début du 19e siècle pour transporter
sa cour et ses nobles seigneurs la
royauté en posséder près de 2000 à la
fin de la monarchie et nécessiter une
sacrée main d'oeuvre cette voiture
devait être tiré par huit chevaux ont
des chevaux de tête étant monté par un
postillon l'écheveau des trois autres
rangs tenu à la main par des valettes
pied et puis il y avait le cocher qui
était juché sur son siège en eau
et puis à la plateforme arrière il y
avait encore quatre capteurs donc tout à
d'entourage tout un service
impressionnant si manuel son insu paulin
c'est pas les machines qui console
salon l'automobile non non non motorisés
et alors ça vous fait rêver ce genre de
véhicule avait par la qualité du travail
par autre chose car au sur mesure pour
le dauphin de louis saez et de
marie-antoinette de l'enfance au mariage
ces attelages luxueux rythmé la vie des
rois les promenant sur les routes de
france y compris jusqu'aux derniers
voyages pour le sud ouest on parle
volontiers de fièvre bleue toute une
région ne vise en effet que pour ça je
parlais de la chasse à la palombe qui
elle est tout à fait autorisé
contrairement à la chasse à la
tourterelle début mai éric perrin et
philippe britten ont suivi une famille
et son filet du côté de sabre dans les
landes et le royaume de la bidouille du
bricolage maison
prenez l'ascenseur pour palombes chargé
d'attirer ses collègues ou encore le
resort jean monsieur muscle c'est un
travail de titan
un travail qui occupe une bonne partie
de la retraite de gérard c'est lui qui a
fait surgir en pleine forêt landaise
cette palombière qu'il faut toujours
perfectionner aménagé camoufler
pour les à l'entretien il faut compter
deux mois j'ai combien là par exemple de
mètres de galeries ici prochain chez
kant 9 350 en bêlant ambulant avec ses
deux gendres jean michel jarre vient
récolter le fruit de son travail des
palombes du pit une sorte de tour de
contrôle
ils surveillent le sol une piste
d'atterrissage agrémenté d'un piège
chasser la palombe
c'est un peu joué aux aiguilleurs du
ciel ça sert à quoi ça sert à prévenir
les problèmes qui sont loués à les plus
rapprochées que la garde il ya les
palombes au four au sol troisième sol
alors gérard ça donne quoi du
conditionnalité énergies fossiles alors
paul est la femme de gérard a apporté de
quoi remonter le moral des troupes
pour le repas elle reichshoffen salmis
de palombes préparé avec l'une des
nombreuses prises de l'année dernière
clé les années se suivent et nous
combien la battre à fait en trois
semaines et nous attraper oui on n'a pas
vu que c'était bien captée et pourtant
aujourd'hui il s'approche enfin
est-ce que vous ressentez là à ce moment
là quotas sont pas très loin comme ça le
coeur qui bat mais allez savoir pourquoi
les palombes resteront dans les arbres
au grand désespoir de la cuisinière dans
l'année vous l'attendez cette période
donc c'est pas fini paulette elles vont
bien finir par venir c'est palombe est
alors la fin de ce journal on ce
dimanche soir il ya urgence à rendre
l'antenne le tente même de vous rappeler
votre rendez vous vers 23h30 pour le
dernier journal en compagnie de florence
dauchez
bonne fête hubert dans un instant la
météo y label martinez avec un lundi
plutôt perturbé sur le nord-ouest à 13h
vous retrouver patrick chêne j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver à 20 heures
excellente soirée merci